well well well 2015.
i mean i was born in 1945 that's 70
years ago a new year
i hope the new year brings every one of
you happiness with your families with
your friends success
uh success in amongst other things your
language learning
i've said that i'm going to keep my
videos short i am
and i'm going to start with a video
which will feature what i think are the
three most important elements to
language learning i've mentioned them
before many times the three golden keys
i've even prepared a little slideshow
which stresses the three golden keys and
i've done a blog post on the three
golden keys
we will leave a little uh links to it
here in the uh
explanation underneath the video so i
wish everyone
success
and i hope you meet your language
learning goals and now uh
for the first of my short videos and
they're not all going to be uh in this
slideshow format but i think these three
keys are so important that i felt it
worthwhile to do this so have a listen
and i look forward to your comments bye
for now
buenos dias
hello
and i could go on in other languages
greeting you
i speak
maybe 10 or 12 languages i understand
15. i've learned about six of them over
the last 10 years i'm in my 70th year i
believe anyone can learn regardless of
their age the key thing is you have to
make up your mind to enjoy the process
and so i'm going to share with you some
of my tips when it comes to learning
languages
i think there are only three things that
really matter one is your attitude two
is the time you spend with the language
and three is your attentiveness i call
this the three golden keys
your attitude that's
seventy percent of the battle
you yourself not the teacher not a
textbook
your attitude
first of all you have to find a way to
enjoy the process you have to like the
language you have to like learning you
have to
learn from things that interest you and
then you have to believe in yourself
believe you will become fluent and don't
worry about what you can't do
give yourself credit for what you can do
do things that you like to do
and of course
you have to want it
badly
so that's the first
golden key the second golden key is to
spend the time spend the time with the
language you have to spend i can't
stress this enough you have to spend
enough time with the language that
doesn't necessarily mean sitting in a
classroom it doesn't mean worrying about
grammar explanations and grammar
exercises it means being with the
language listening to it reading it and
when you're ready for talking and even
writing
and doing this
around subjects that are interesting to
you and that give you enjoyment and of
course you have to make the time find
the time 10 minutes here five minutes
there and do it regularly and you have
to be prepared for a long journey
the next and perhaps the most difficult
key
is attentiveness
what do we mean by attentiveness well
there's a famous sufi
muslim
proverb it's which says you can only
learn what you already know you have to
develop that ability to notice and that
is something that we acquire
gradually
attentiveness is a skill that you
acquire
and it depends on your attitude you have
to want to notice and you have to spend
time with the language
and you have to be motivated
and then what starts to happen is
you start to notice certain patterns and
once you notice them then you can learn
them and the more things you notice the
more new things you notice and of course
all of this depends on you taking charge
of your own learning
so once again the three golden keys
your attitude the time you spend with
the language and your attentiveness to
what's happening in the language
or